Hi there.
So I thought I'd update you with regards
to what has been going on at the
University of Toronto in the last week.
Um,
since I released my three videos
starting on September 27th dealing with
political correctness,
uh,
at the legislative level and in terms of
certain policy decisions at the
University of Toronto,
most particularly the mandatory
requirement that the human resources
staff take a antiracism and antibiotics
training.
So on October 3rd,
I received the first of two warning
letters,
um,
telling me that I was required to act in
accordance with university policies and
with the relevant law.
I'm not going to read you the first
letter.
Um,
but I'll read you the second one,
which I got on October 18th.
So dear Professor Peterson,
we are writing in followup to professor
ferber's letter to you of October 3rd,
2016.
Professor Ferber is the chair of the
psychology department and um,
she gave me the first letter,
um,
as a consequence of her interactions
with a variety of administrators at the
university
regarding the ongoing concerns related
to your videos and complaints that have
been made to the university by members
of the university community,
including transgendered persons and the
organizations that represent and support
them on campus about some of the content
of those videos.
First,
let us be clear that the university is
committed to the protection of freedom
of speech as a core value for our
community and for any university in a
democratic society.
The university is likewise committed to
protecting the academic freedom of our
faculty members,
including their right to criticize the
university and society at large with
freedom from institutional censorship.
As articulated in article five of the
Memorandum of agreement between the
University of Toronto and the University
of Toronto Faculty Association,
the University's commitment to
protecting these core values includes
your right to express and debate views
that may be discomforting or even
offensive to others.
However,
as professor ferber has already pointed
out to you,
these rights are not without limitation
and must be exercised in accordance with
your responsibilities as a faculty
member,
including upholding applicable laws.
You have continued to state public
publicly that if a student or colleague
or staff member requests that you
referred to the music,
gender neutral pronouns,
you will refuse to do so and that you do
not recognize the rights of others to
tell you which personal pronoun to use
when addressing them.
The law of Ontario,
specifically the Ontario Human Rights
Code protects against discrimination
based on gender expression and gender
identity.
Depending on the context,
if personal pronouns are being used,
the refusal by a teacher or colleague to
use the personal pronoun,
that is an expression of the person's
gender identity can constitute
discrimination.
In many situations.
It is not necessary to use personal
pronouns at all,
but where it is the personal pronoun
that is chosen as the person's gender
identity related and gender expression
related identifier should be used.
Your statements that you will refuse to
use transgendered your statements that
you will refuse to refer to
transgendered persons using gender
neutral pronouns if they ask you to do
so are contrary to the rights of those
persons to equal treatment without
discrimination based on their gender
identity and gender expression.
You should also be aware that many
members of the university community are
concerned and distressed about the
declarations of your discriminatory
intentions.
The university has received
communications from individual student
groups and employee groups that find my
comments to be unacceptable,
emotionally disturbing and painful.
Some members of the university community
report that the statements and the
invective that has followed in the
ensuing commentary and debates on social
media have caused them to fear for their
safety on the university campus.
Some students have reported being the
target of specific and violent threats
including threats of assault,
injury,
and death against them individually and
as members of the Trans Community.
We trust that these impacts on students
and others were not your intention in
making these remarks.
However,
in view of these impacts as well as the
requirements of the Ontario Human Rights
Code,
we urge you to stop repeating these
statements.
As professor ferber informed you,
your responsibilities as a faculty
member at the University of Toronto
include an obligation to uphold the law,
including the Ontario human rights code
and to do so as you exercise your
academic freedom or freedom of
expression,
your responsibilities as a faculty
member also include dealing with other
members of the university community in
ways that provide equal treatment
without discrimination.
Article Five of the memo of agreement
between New Toronto and and the U
Toronto Faculty Association not only
recognizes that faculty members have the
right to academic freedom,
but also notes the responsibility of
faculty members to establish fair and
ethical dealings with students as well
as with colleagues.
The impact of your behavior runs the
risk of undermining your ability to
conduct essential components of your job
as a faculty member,
and we urge you to consider your
obligations as a faculty member to act
in a manner that is consistent with the
law and with university policy.
You have referred to allegations of
criminal behavior by some in at the
Rally of October 11th,
2016 the university deplores acts of
violence and it's just rupture of civil
debate.
The allegations of criminal behavior are
being investigated by the Toronto Police
Service.
The university continues to emphasize to
its community members the obligation to
engage in civil nonviolent interactions
at all times,
including when difficult topics are
discussed on campus.
Yours sincerely,
David Cameron,
Dean Faculty of Arts and Science.
See your band,
Nelson,
vice provost,
faculty and academic life copied to
professors,
Suzanne Ferber,
chair of the Department of Psychology.
So
I'm being urged to stop saying what I'm
saying.
Well,
the next video I'll post and hopefully
today will be my response to that.